so the republican national convention
continued yesterday yesterday was day
two
it was definitely a different day than
day one there was less screaming from
the speakers although eric trump
did a little bit of screaming but it was
sort of
a weaker day from the standpoint of
making the case that donald trump should
be re-elected some of the major speeches
yesterday including melania trump's
said a lot but didn't actually explain
why what they said means or points to
re-electing donald trump and i'm going
to get to that in a moment but if i had
to sort of give a very broad overview
day one was
erratic screaming kimberly guilfoyle
donald trump jr whereas day two
was more trying to
be more precise trying to be more
calm about the trump administration
being a real administration a
respectable administration and having
earned four more years but failing to do
so and not really making that case and
it also included day two did
some horrible breaches of protocol
possibly even of the law
before day two even started by the way
one of the speakers
was removed from a montage because it
was
revealed that she previously tweeted
anti-semitic
conspiracy theories this was marianne
mendoza
her police officer son was tragically
killed by a drunk driver
she was going to be included in a list
of speaker excerpts remarks
and uh it became known that she had
previously retweeted a thread
on twitter promoting anti-semitic
conspiracies so she was pulled from the
evening program i mean just every detail
beyond parody and exactly what
the stereotypes about these types of
events are actually
meeting that standard that expectation
conforming to it
melania trump spoke from the white house
rose garden now
it was a rose garden devoid of roses
very
strange updates to the landscaping made
in advance of melania trump's speech
which shouldn't even have taken place
really the white house not supposed to
be used as a political prop not supposed
to be used
um for political events and they did
there will be no repercussions don't
even think about it i know it's
frustrating but there's just not going
to be any repercussions for that
but the most notable thing to me from
day two
was the degree to which it was filled
with bold-faced lies
provable lies and this was another
distinction from day one
not only less screaming on day two
day one more optics and propaganda that
are less simply
factually false day one had a lot of
north korea-like imagery from kimberly
guilfoyle
obviously nonsense but not as many
straight-up
factual lies yesterday was just
laughable obvious provable empirical lie
after lie and we're going to go through
some of them maybe the funniest
was when former florida attorney general
pam bondi
claimed that what she did as florida
attorney general
was fight corruption check this out and
then i'll remind you why it's so wild
but for joe biden it's been the land of
opportunism
not opportunity as a career prosecutor
and former attorney general of florida
i fought corruption and i know what it
looks like
whether it's done by people wearing
pinstripe suits or
orange jumpsuits pam bondi says
that she fought corruption as attorney
general in florida
she was investigating trump university
as attorney general in florida trump
donated to her re-election campaign
and the investigation went away and she
has the audacity
to brazenly say that she fought
corruption as attorney general in
florida
she was corrupt as attorney general in
florida
pam bondi also criticized joe biden for
nepotism
and then was followed up yesterday by
tiffany trump
eric trump and melania trump again
saturday night live can't do anything
with it it's beyond parody
uh tiffany trump did speak as i
mentioned she's donald trump sort of
less
public daughter um it wasn't
really clear it hasn't been clear that
tiffany trump likes her dad
and it certainly wasn't clear yesterday
but she did speak
she bizarrely claimed that people are
enslaved by the media
and coerced by the media and by tech
giants
very unusual imagery take a look of who
we are
voting for may and are being manipulated
and visibly coerced by the media and
tech giants
if you tune into the media you get one
biased opinion
or another and what you share if it does
not fit into the narrative that they
seek to promote
then it is either ignored or deemed a
lie regardless of the truth
this manipulation of what information we
receive
impedes our freedoms rather than
allowing americans
the right to form our own beliefs this
misinformation system keeps
people mentally enslaved enslaved i mean
really powerful language tiffany's
speech
again it wasn't just low energy
it didn't make the case for donald
trump's re-election and that was what
was interesting about
about a lot of the speeches yesterday
including melania's which we're going to
get to
which was that so much was said but
it wasn't clear why anybody should vote
for donald trump on the basis of the
speeches that were made
trump's son eric trump spoke and again
lame lies nonsense but here is
one of the whoppers that eric told just
making things up out of thin air
it's in the middle east never ending
wars were finally ended
now of course donald trump did not
achieve peace in the middle east you
probably know that
donald trump did not end any wars you
probably know that it just didn't happen
these are provable empirical lies we
then heard from trump economic adviser
larry kudlow
who showed up and just told a complete
fantasy
about the trump administration's
handling of coronavirus and
in that context of the economy take a
look at this one once in 100 year
pandemic
it was awful health and economic impacts
were tragic
hardship and heartbreak were everywhere
but
presidential leadership came swiftly and
effectively
with an extraordinary rescue for health
and safety
to successfully fight the covet virus so
to his credit larry kudlow didn't seem
drunk this time that's good
but he wasn't making any sense anyway
and of course this administration
did not put together the brilliant
health and economic plan that larry
kudlow
wants us to believe they put together
and in fact
the trump administration response was
one of the worst responses to the virus
in the world
and led to not only unnecessary death
but also unnecessary economic
destruction
they didn't create the virus they're not
responsible for the virus
but they are responsible for one of the
worst responses larry kudlow also by the
way
as many speakers did on day one and on
day two
kudlow refers to coronavirus and the
pandemic in the past tense
you might be interested to know just to
be anchored to reality that coronavirus
killed another
1291 people in the united states
yesterday alone they continue to pretend
that it's over and they need to
they need to and that's why they've been
doing it for months coronavirus ranks as
one of the most important issues for
voters
and one of the ones where donald trump
has the lowest approval rating so they
have to pretend it's over they have to
claim
that donald trump managed it very well
now one of the propaganda elements
that's concerning many people from
yesterday
is that uniformed members of the
military were pulled into the evening
which isn't supposed to happen for
example we're showing video
of uniformed marines when donald trump
did a naturalization ceremony at the
white house for new
citizens um marines and members of the
military are not supposed to be
political figures in political videos
and the entire night was filled with
this now the response from the white
house was
these events were white house formal
events
the video was then made public and the
public video was then used at the rnc
so at the time that the uniformed
marines
were filmed these were not
political events but they were white
house events
i don't think i have to say too much
more about that reasoning
another propaganda element was trump
springing a pardon
on a guy after a whole propagandistic
montage
and again donald trump creating
something out of nothing
take a look at this video listen to this
to join us
as i grant john i'm not sure you know
this
a full pardon
so i don't know if you know that jamie
come on over here
it's just an honor and you've done
incredible work thank you sir
and all of las vegas and all of nevada
and all of every place in this country
is very proud of you the job you've done
bringing people back and you're right i
was supposed to be there for five
minutes i stayed for an hour and a half
because it was so interesting to me
congratulations you really get the sense
that donald trump doesn't really
understand what he's doing
but he imagines or envisions that it
looks great to people
and that they're going to be incredibly
moved by it when it's just awkward more
than anything else
and then the night capped off the
keynote of the evening last night
was melania trump a very long speech
completely meandering if you said what
was the speech about i couldn't tell you
there was really no
arc to it there was no coherent
narrative
and it certainly didn't make the case
for why donald trump should be
re-elected
donald trump did not seem pleased during
it in fact as we're showing people he
looked like
very much like he was not enjoying
himself every time that the camera would
cut to him during the speech
and it was a lame speech here's a few
moments melania saying that donald trump
this is funny
that trump doesn't play politics and
even she seems to have a hard time
believing that
donald wants to keep your family safe he
wants to
help your family succeed he wants
nothing more
than for this country to prosper and he
doesn't waste time playing politics
now oh yeah what what i didn't like was
i saw a lot of people supposedly on the
left
for example during my live streams
yesterday ridiculing melania for her
accent
listen she's not from the united states
people have accents
when they learn languages as adults i do
think
it's beneath us to go after her for her
accent we should go after donald trump
because he has one position on
immigration
and then we learned that his wife was
working in the united states at a time
when she was not authorized to work in
the united states that's against the law
we that
that's fair game um melania's parents
got
special treatment and became citizens
melania got an einstein visa
all of that is completely fair game her
accent is not
fair game for me i think the left should
stay away from that i think it does
absolutely nothing for us
now here melania trump seems to sort of
find the solution to racism in some
weird way take a look
with that in mind i like to call on the
citizens of this country
to take a moment pause and look at
things from all perspectives
i urge people to come together in a
civil manner
so we can work and live up to our
standard american ideals
i also ask people to stop the violence
and looting being done in the name of
justice
and never make assumptions based on the
color
of a person's skin yeah guys i mean just
stop the violence stop the looting and
stop the racism
oh all right and and then again how that
links to trump's reelection
is beyond me there were some really
cringy applause lines
where it sort of became clear that
people were supposed to clap but
always like half a beat too late for
example melania pausing
when she said that she became a citizen
after passing a test
and it was just really really awkward
but i wanted more
i wanted to be a citizen after 10 years
of paperwork and patience i studied for
the test
in 2006 and became an american citizen
so again the real critique of this
speech
is there was no coherent story there was
no coherent arc it was terribly written
but more importantly these musings from
melania trump
don't make the case effectively for
donald trump's re-election
now you and i would say you can't
possibly make that case because
he doesn't deserve to be re-elected and
i would agree with you but
typically no matter how bad a first term
has been
a convention speech is able to put
together a story
at least plausibly justifying if you buy
into it
the re-election of the sitting president
melania's speech didn't even do that
and quite frankly for all we know she
doesn't even want donald trump to be
re-elected
my sense from day one has been she
didn't want to be the first lady of the
united states
she just wanted to marry a rich guy and
travel from penthouse to penthouse on
trump's private plane i don't think she
really wants any part of this i don't
think it's been particularly good
for her uh and again yesterday we
learned that she had been
she has been caught on recordings
disparaging donald trump disparaging
trump's adult children
it's not even clear she wanted to be
giving this speech
but it is what it is i guess to quote
donald trump
uh tonight is night three we're
expecting scheduled although always
subject to change if someone gets caught
tweeting something anti-semitic they may
be pulled but
we're expecting vice president mike
pence tonight his wife karen pence
uh a bunch of other members of congress
kellyanne conway who recently announced
she's quitting in five days
she's scheduled to speak tonight eric
trump's wife lara trump
expected tonight so join me for day
three
i'll be starting the live coverage on
our youtube
and twitch channels at about quarter
past 8 p.m eastern time 8 15 p.m eastern
5 15 p.m pacific and
like two in the morning uh uh western
europe time a lot of people staying up
late with us for these
conventions join me tonight in the
meantime let me know your thoughts
via twitter i'm on twitter dpakman you
can find me there
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors sussman and
han
sussman and han has everything you need
when it comes to face masks and other
protective gear
for covid19 and they're giving my
audience 20 off
sussman and han is the company that i
personally have been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor
i have tried tons of different masks
this year
and i still have not found a mask that's
more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cotton
that feels great on your skin
it has convenient adjustable straps it
features a disposable five layer
particle filter made of activated carbon
they also have disposable cloth masks
which are really comfortable as well as
other gear
like face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers
and all of their prices are very
reasonable i also love sussman and han
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions they're
a great company
you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is underneath this video
and you can save 20
off of everything in their store when
you use the coupon code david